[Musik]
mami hätten sie begangen von aktien in
papiere im april 2000 50 gestorbene mann
einfach abgenommen ich zwölf bin ich
muss sagen wo es doch passiert mir wieso
muss ich jetzt genau der rucksack mit
mehr mittragen
suizid ist sehr viel komplexere prozesse
umsetzen todesfall durch zu erkranken
sich ganze menschengruppen die person
was ich töte hat wobei der stadt und
sich mit fragen konfrontiert sieht vor
allem mit tragen haben und fragen von
schuld
[Musik]
suizid hinterbliebenen zu helfen ist
seine lebensaufgabe jörg weißhaupt er
kennt den schmerz der bleibt wenn ihr
liebte nahestehende einen verlassen
seine frau starb an krebs einer seiner
söhne erlagen im hirntumore der
62-jährige war sekundarlehrer danach 30
jahre lang jugendbeauftragte der
reformierten kirche zürich er engagierte
sich auch für die sms seelsorge zum
beispiel sms roaming freundin kundus
psychiatrische klinik nach einem
suizidversuch
wie kann ich jede druck auf den alltag
und das hat mich mittlerweile gemerkt
haben also prävention ist schon da und
das thema aber zu ziehen ach so da
gibt's kein geld da gibt es eine kasse
engagement
er setzt sich mit leib und seele für die
suizid prävention und nachsorge 1
auch pfarrer simon gaps ist ihm
geblieben sein bruder nahm sich vor 31
jahren das leben
simon caps will in der fernsehsendung
wort zum sonntag darüber sprechen was
ein suizid bei den hinterbliebenen
auslöst in wetzlar fokussierter was
braucht mein freund feststellung herbert
durch suizid um hilf richtig wenn man
sie wertneutral also wenn man werden
neutral aufrecht oder mit ihnen
rettungswunder fragt sondern muss ein
land das gespürt ihr unglaublich
zudem habe durch sein engagement für
hinterbliebene trifft jörg weißhaupt oft
auf menschen die traumatisiert sind
das thema verfolgt mich auf schritt und
tritt
ich danke das betrifft mich jedes mal
von neuem und das dem auch teilnehmer
er wird nicht ab kehrte die dem sind
dass ein dass hitler größe miteinander
herzlichen dank für stahl vor dem
workshop zum thema suizid prävention
es ist ganz wichtig dass man über das
thema redet miteinander
mein name ist erweist auch hier an der
pädagogischen hochschule zürich ist
suizid ein thema informieren aufklären
das tabu brechen jörg weißhaupt
engagiert sich in der suizidprävention
des kantons zürich und er initiierte
mehrere selbsthilfegruppen für
hinterbliebene in verschiedenen kantonen
und leitet diese zum teil auch im
workshop für zukünftige sekundarstufen
lehrkräfte geht es um die frage wie
gehen wir mit suizid um mich würde
interessieren was sind jetzt für fragen
oder wann sie öfters in die dav
regierung betroffenheit eine trennung
war sehr schön
ich möchte dass sich dort auch gemalt
hat für den kurs wenn sie sauber
diese frage mit suizid kreis der
personen gehabt und man hört jährlich
sowie zieht versuche der schweiz und du
sicher hoch die suizid jetzt ohne die
assistierte als ohne sterbehilfe weiß
noch wie soll kommen die haben raus sind
kaum älter als 30 so hat wie geht man
damit um wenn dann aber über krieg oder
sollten es will ich thematisiere der
mitteklasse ja wir kommunizieren dass
man einfach nur darüber gleich wird
musik seiten ist das quartier gerät wird
über achteinhalb mütter sondern nur für
die persönliche erfahrung oder die
jugendlich sie
in einer jugendgruppe um ihren themen
anbieten filmplakat ich weiß nicht mehr
genau wie heißt mit dem stress sie einen
schweizer film und in dem film bringt
mich ein abschlepper weil er im
rollstuhl sitzt und am nächsten tag ein
mann später erfahren jetzt noch einen
tag später erfahre was ich eine von
dieser gruppe der 4 und claus kleber
knallt und das ist für ostern schuh ja
nicht ganz so dominant dass wir müssen
weiter
männer die sich das leben nehmen
sie sind in der überzahl in der schweiz
bringen sich mehr als doppelt so viele
männer wie frauen um völlig unverhofft
niemand mit der dort kollegen und ich
hoffe dass das auch die menschen mit
perfektion ist ischen andere verlage
oder was man sich vorgestellt dass ich
selber als unfall
und irgendwann einmal ein punkt und und
man den hut nehmen
gerade einfach nehmen und dann noch
fähig ist das kommunizieren und hilfen
aus brüssel
die wahrscheinlichkeit ist hoch dass
lehrerinnen und lehrer im berufsumfeld
mit dem thema suizid konfrontiert werden
in der schweiz nehmen sich täglich drei
menschen das leben
zurück bleiben tausende angehörige wut
trauer und vielen fragen
für jörg weißhaupt ist klar in der
schweiz noch zu wenig getan für die
suizid prävention und nachsorge
also mein herz gehört vor der student
aus überrascht dass er so viel mehr tote
als frears tote gibt
das wichtigste thema im land mit
betroffenheit viel größer ist als die
der gesellschaft
[Musik]
21 jahre lang konnte jörg weißhaupt die
nachsorge für suizid hinterbliebene im
auftrag der reformierten kirche zürich
aufbauen
[Musik]
doch dann 2017 war schluss die
kirchenleitung argumentierte sowie zieht
nachsorge sei nicht aufgabe der
reformierten kirche zürich wo viele
entschieden hat dass nämlich eigentlich
für ist für mich das muss wieder für
travel so schwächte bis und stadt
sicherlich ist das konzept suizid stadt
nun bereits in der schweiz also ein
sitzt du dir suizid wo sich manche
selber tötet apparatur dann natürlich
die aktivität der
sterbehilfeorganisationen und darum
finde ich unverantwortlich los von dem
viele man die zeit nehmen um so mehr
setzte sich dann jörg weißhaupt für
seine selbsthilfegruppen 1
sie heißen nebelmeer ich erinnere mich
auch eine geschichte die uns noch das
kriegsschiff beachten dass sie de facto
mit tritten stuttgart und seit noah im
halbschlaf bodyguard und sie weg und
weil er dem team aus wird der schuss
gehört und die nur der hat noch in einen
seite also wenn ich noch ein kind war
ich am liebsten auch gegangen
und die sind heimlich zug grübelt
ich habe den ich mit mit eine schlimme
geschichte mit einem dramatischen
geschichte auseinandersetzen warum warum
heute das projekt will das gegenüber der
gruppe ein mensch wo nach perspektive
fürs lager sucht also wo realisiert der
verlust wird immer ein teil von mir aber
das ist meine geschichte mit mir gott
aber sind manche in der gruppe wo über
nachfolger gott immer mehr junge
menschen wo
vielleicht in der ausbildung sind im
beruf stehen und sagen ich habe mich
bewusst mit der tour und dem verlust
auseinander
[Musik]
sarah will leben
die 22 jährige studentin ist
hinterbliebene ihre mutter nahm sich vor
sechs jahren das leben
deshalb geht sie seit einem knappen jahr
in die selbsthilfegruppe nebelmeer hier
verarbeitet sie den suizid ihrer mutter
im gespräch mit jörg weißhaupt ist dass
diese empfinde sie hat weder glücklich
sind aus als tochter so rasch
mitzuhalten stand ein akzeptanz spüre
ich zu hause und hörte und ihre die tat
natürlich das nicht moralisieren
kritisieren abschiedsbrief ist das keine
wünsche ich schon die letzten gut
ich weiß sehr genau und wenn sie dich
gern gerade erst hat die quantität und
wenn ich sehr schön dass du wie du mit
dem suizid für ihre umgangs und das mit
der würdevolle haltung gegenüber ungarn
also wenn du dass er sowas spüre ich
dass sie glaubt wunder dass man das dann
halt noch richtige ort da sein
britisches so wichtig wie erzieht
derzeit verlaufen die staatliche zum
verlust der umgang mit der natur und mit
den verlusten geschlossen
die aktive haltung es ist sehr wertvoll
für die zukunft
[Musik]
jörg weißhaupt weiß wie verlust schmerzt
sich anfühlt eines seiner drei kinder
starb an einem hirntumor
[Musik]
es ist noch kein jahr her dass er
gestorben ist und dafür mit mir herum
liegen hat die letzte woche in seen und
in begleitet haben oft ins spital zu den
unterschied
ich denke ich immer ein teil von mir und
das sind verschiedene etappen
abschiedstournee also seite ist da das
begräbnis xiii und top picks 4
ich glaube es ist immer wieder das
abschiede
[Musik]
auch seine frau ist hier begraben sie
verstarb vor fünf jahren an krebs
termine für ihre bezugspersonen feld
hälfte oder die freihand 1
das merke ich schon dass sie schnitten
und die zwei todesfall in der familie
energie und knappe und tod gehören als
[Musik]
persönlich spüre ich schreibe eigentlich
dass bücher dann hat das immer wieder
spielt dass der hund kann halt gemacht
hat gestaltet hat geschrieben hat das
ist im trude oder für die tour prozesse
bis sehr wichtig wir mussten alle drei
weinen und haben uns fest aneinander
gehalten und dann schreibt sie weiter
ich glaube ich wollte ihm bliebe ich hat
jetzt die situation überhaupt nicht
verstehe und metalle es tut mir so
unendlich weh dass man mit trennt sie
droht jetzt aktiven wanderer auf
zusammen trauern zusammen abschied
nehmen jörg weißhaupt konnte das im
gegensatz zu suizid hinterbliebenen sie
bleiben oft alleine zurück mit fragen um
verständnis und schuldgefühle habe der
fokus der planer auch meine
suizidgefährdet für unsere gesellschaft
was aber wieder im griff über
hochschalten perspektive suche für ihn
zukommt und darum glaube ich ist wichtig
dass wir jetzt einfach dem symposium
personen wo im bereich vom gesundheits
weise tätig sind sensibilisiert für
psychiater und psychotherapeut innen
zeigt jörg weißhaupt auf welche
dramatischen folgen ein suizid für
hinterbliebene haben kann
eine junge frau 29 sachbearbeiterin
erlebt dass sich ihr partner das leben
nimmt in der gemeinsamen wohnung hat er
sich erschossen sie findet ihn er hat
ihr das ein ganzes leben vor gespielt
also sie wusste nicht dass er nicht mehr
im arbeitsprozess darin ist er hat
jahrelang sein scheitern kassiert der
erschwerte trauerprozess zeigt sich
darin dass sie erst nach seinem tode
realisiert er hat mich eigentlich nur
angelogen das ganze leben die ganze
beziehung oder eine lüge dazu kam nach
dem erfolgten suizid die
schuldzuweisungen seien der eltern an
sie an die überlebende person und die
enttäuschung ihrer mutter dass diese
beziehung nicht mehr ist spielt auch
eine große rolle in dieser
kompliziertheit des prozesses solche
traumatischen erlebnisse haben
konsequenzen suizid hinterbliebene sind
oft selbst suizid gefährdet
deshalb ist es jörg weißhaupt ein großes
anliegen das thema zu enttabuisieren
ich glaube es ist schon dringt das
nützlich bewusst wird dass der suizid
nicht einfach möglich beendet
sonderschicht vor allem vom umfeld und
vor allem komplizierte geschichte von
jörg weißhaupt trifft sich mit zwei
ehemaligen mitgliedern der
selbsthilfegruppe nebelmeer christinas
mutter sowie zitierte sich hat sie zwölf
war marias vater nahm sich das leben
während einem klinikaufenthalt 14
stunden danach von der fakt ist ich muss
das machen damit ich wieder im rhythmus
bekommen damit ich das auch arbeiter
entlassen
dank der trauer und verarbeitungsprozess
konnten sie den suizid ihres elternteils
verarbeiten und sind nicht mehr auf
unterstützung angewiesen
christina ist heute projektleiterin im
bereich lärmschutz zweifache mutter
manuela architektin jetzt brauche die
gruppen immer
für mich ist entscheidend dass ich
gemerkt dass ich mir meine themen vor
dem verarbeitungsprozess hat nie richtig
gepasst was heißt dass arbeite und wohne
ich aufgehört haben ich habe akzeptiert
dass teil von ihrer geschichte womit die
gespräche mit seinen mitgliedern im
endlauf stadt heiß und er nach einer
bleibe am anfang ich mir ja aber wo viel
mitteilt
zwischendrin mitteile und zu hören
und weil mir schon lange bin ich glaube
ich sehr viel zum zuhörer und auch
versucht tipps gehe aber die eigene
geschichte machen wir vielleicht noch
mal und noch mal und noch mal für zeller
und die allgemeinheit ich das einfach
nur zur verbreitung rechter kommuniziert
dass ein suizid hinterlässt sie haben
gelernt damit zu leben
weniger streng
[Musik]
schließlich im moment und muss halt
gelernt dass nicht alles immer nach plan
geht er seine sache auch eine andere
strecke enthemmte
wenn sie fragen oder werden sie ich kann
einfach dateien immer und dass das
passiert und mir gegenüber jahres ein
tabuisiertes thema es ist ein
schicksalsschlag also irgendwie prägt
immer und ich finde es richtig dass
möchte was macht und stärke